what do you think it means to be a good
citizen
what does a good citizen do take a
minute to imagine
your idea of a good citizen what
characteristics does that person have
what actions does that person take that
contribute
to their status as an active and
virtuous citizen
i encourage you to pause the video here
and write down
a few words or examples
okay so what did you come up with did
you think of
someone who obeys the law treats others
with kindness
volunteers maybe spends their money
wisely
what about someone who is active in
politics
or organizes community responses to
problems
like starting a food drive or maybe you
thought about someone who
tries to solve problems facing society
by
advocating for change maybe working to
change
laws or larger social structures in
order to promote justice and equality
so which one is right okay yeah you
guessed it it's a trick question
in fact these are all models of good
citizenship
and i want to dive a little more deeply
into each of them
to give you a sense of what they mean
because if you compare what you
jotted down when i asked you to imagine
a good citizen
to what your friend or your parent or
your teacher imagined
you might find that they had something
entirely different in mind
so it's helpful to be able to name
different visions for good citizenship
so that you can probe a little more
deeply into what someone really means
when they're talking about
it the first model you might see is that
of the personally responsible citizen
this is a model of citizenship that
focuses on the actions an
individual can take to be a good member
of their community
a personally responsible citizen
fulfills their personal obligations
and acts responsibly they pay their
taxes
vote obey the law and volunteer to help
the less fortunate
they are honest and work hard what
separates this model
from the other two we're going to talk
about is that the personally responsible
citizen
generally doesn't try to change society
or lead efforts to improve their
community
they just do their part the second model
i want to talk about
is participatory citizenship this model
emphasizes community action and
organizing
the participatory citizen might create a
group to advocate for
environmental protection or organize a
blood drive at their school or workplace
they believe in working collectively
with others to address
problems in their communities they tend
to work through
established systems and groups to enact
change which distinguishes them from the
last
model i want to talk about the
justice-oriented citizen
a big difference between the justice
oriented citizen
and the participatory citizen is that
participatory citizens don't attempt to
change
big underlying social problems like
poverty or racism
they organize to meet the challenges of
the world as it is
so let's talk a little bit more about
this third model
the justice oriented citizen the justice
oriented citizen
is interested in addressing social
issues
and the larger structures that lead to
injustice
they try to take a step back from
society as it is
to ask why problems happen and seek
solutions
to their root causes so for a justice
oriented citizen giving to charity
or organizing a group to combat a social
problem
isn't enough they want to stop that
problem from happening in the future
now i'm not telling you this because i
want to convince you that there's a
correct
or a best way to be a good citizen
all three of these models are doing good
in their communities
just in different ways and with
different areas of focus
i'm also not saying that you have to
choose one of these models to follow
there's nothing stopping you from doing
a little bit of all three
or taking one approach with an issue you
care about and
a different approach with another issue
but understanding
these different approaches to
citizenship will help you communicate
more clearly with others about how you
can work together to improve your
community
before we go let's do a quick scenario
so you can get in some practice
i'll give you some examples of students
responding to
a problem at their school and you see if
you can identify
which model of citizenship each student
represents
so here's the problem the marching band
doesn't have
enough money to attend the battle of the
big bands
where they're going to compete for best
regional marching band
gabe who plays the tuba decides to
organize
a bake sale in order to raise money for
the band trip
bodhi who plays the flute bakes brownies
and buys
rice krispie treats for all of her
friends to support the cause
nadia who plays alto sax wonders why the
marching band doesn't have as much
funding as some
other school clubs she presents in front
of the school board
requesting equal funding per student for
extracurricular activities
which model of citizenship does each of
these students represent
gabe is modeling participatory
citizenship
he is organizing a community response to
a problem
bodhi is modeling personally responsible
citizenship
she does her part in the bake sale nadia
is modeling justice-oriented citizenship
she wants to make sure that the systems
are in place to keep problems like this
from happening
in the first place so which model of
citizenship do you think
you most often practice does your family
school social group promote one of these
models more than another
do you think there are other models of
citizenship that we haven't identified
here